hey guys righteous Ryan in the house and
Katie Dubois in the house in the house
so today we're gonna check out the
trailer for a ball started the rock look
at that
feel that rock solid rock solid very
nice yeah that hurt don't touch me I'm
like that now okay so let's watch his
HBO thing - the rocks involved in my
dreams all about deals and dollars I'm a
financial manager and I will put your
money to work
where are the three most important
things you miss Peter birds yeah
god yeah that's good for a second - I
thought you were gonna shave friends
this ball a wash
gorgeous the second guys hit on me today
is it the Axe body spray telling
I can trust you with this event is
strictly corporate we have a work
I want to be rich now we were gonna drop
it again but no no we did indicating
unfortunately Wow
wow that looks like looks like contours
yeah yeah it kinda has an entourage feel
living it up life on HBO's show it
what's the rocks embalming is is he act
the actual star of the show it looks
like he is that's kind of weird he's
such a big movie star normally people
will do that if like their careers
dipping or their career as we really
dipped and like he is like top of the
top yeah but he has a pretty narrow sort
of Avenue to go down I mean this is his
no yeah that's kind of platform and
what's cool about it is it's the rock
just given a performance to it's not
like an action movie role he's just
doing it like I don't know if there's
gonna be a what do you mean Katie what
do you mean it's not an action movie
he's not playing football though I'm
right you're wrong
okay what's your opinion it just seems
like he's just a badass like he's always
a badass I mean here he's he's a he's a
financial badass but he's just gonna
strut around saying badass things and
flashing his handsome smile and muscles
that's his badass hurry
yeah but he doesn't always quite succeed
at being a badass Fast Five I thought he
was so cheesy didn't he also do like a
daddy daycare thing or something like
that is Eddie Murphy has racist that is
Vin Diesel you racist he didn't he
didn't do a kid's thing he did what was
it something about football like his
daughter shows up he's like I didn't
know how to kid and it's a funny movie
he plays what the financial manager of
the team okay
this reminds me a lot of movies like
boiler room okay [ __ ] like Wolf of
Wall Street and yeah so you think it's
gonna be a little more dynamic yeah you
get some challenges they're probably
gonna be playing and then BAM digging
into the rich [ __ ] lifestyle
and then BAM it just starts getting
really
dark and depressing and then in the end
we learned that greed is not good I
don't think we're gonna learn that no
it's a series so we probably wouldn't
even learn that for a while would be
mean it looks like fun I don't know how
they're getting at a female demographic
on board for this oh I know right really
yeah I mean you know emotionally I'm not
that excited about it but I mean that
boy he was like stood up and he was just
mm I'm sorry
that's so weird that you have a thing
for muscles I have a thing I'm not
family
yeah only girl when we girl who likes
muscles I like fat girls someone thing
my girlfriend is really disappointing me
and she'll take that as a compliment
okay okay look baby I wish you were fed
there's a few phases I saw on this Peter
bird I wonder if he's involved in
directing this too he did Friday Night
Lights and he did Hancock - very similar
movies oh and he's worked with the rock
before he weren't he directed the
rundown so I think the family keeping it
in the family the rock did family movies
he became part of the Fast and Furious
family now he's doing more family stuff
Rob Corddry car adopts so that would
names today Rob Corddry is a funny ass
comedian I'm probably pronouncing his
name wrong he's perfect for these kinds
of movies too it's that's what I mean it
kind of does remind me of like wolf of
wallstreet how they're getting like a
comedian like they got Jonah Hill for
wolf of Wall Street and they got this
guy to play the supporting role - yeah
going back to the thing about the rock
there's one movie I saw of him where I
was like fantastic performance from the
rock and it wasn't an action movie and
he could have just been a badass but it
was pain and gain and I feel like he can
provide something different for this
role - you know kind of like the Ari
Gold of it all well HBO also is known
for more dynamic TV shows so that's
probably part of the puzzle here yeah
they probably know what they're doing
there's just seated a few times once or
twice no but really they still gotta
prove themselves we're being very
sincere by the way anyway guys if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
Reading System now okay I'm a TV show
rating system it's
to be going to tune in every week wait
for the season to come out or not even
bother I'm gonna wait for the season to
come out on this one I don't feel like I
need a tune in every week to this show
I'm gonna wait for Ryan to tell me I
should watch it yeah
or oh yeah well I'll watch it if you
guys really want me to watch it
you can follow real rejects on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter you follow her on
Facebook and Twitter you have a Facebook
fan page I do yeah follower there not a
personal one it's more serious yeah this
is what everyone does for serious actor
I just did pose like Michelangelo's
painting yeah all right cool and then um
boom you're closing jokey you want a
really corny joke I could go for corny
tortilla chip we told you that